[Music]
rob kardashian squared off which is ex
blac chyna oh these two love attention
don't they oh you probably read about
them at each other's throats for weeks
but today Michelle Turner was in the
courtroom where it seems like China okay
I would like to first and foremost thank
the judge for granting me this
restraining order to protect me and I'm
just gonna get back to co-parenting
dream under the terms of today's
temporary restraining order Rob
Kardashian is ordered to stay at least
100 yards away from China he also is not
allowed to post any pictures of her or
their daughter dream the judge also said
that Rob in China would continue to
share custody of dream and exchange the
child through their caregivers all of
this after Rob social media meltdown
last week when he accused China of
cheating he also posted explicit images
of her and that could land him in even
more legal trouble revenge porn is a
form of domestic abuse it is also a
crime in California and 38 other states
it's important to point out that Rob has
not been charged with a crime and
according to his attorney he did not
contest the restraining order he was not
in court today but he was represented by
Robert Shapiro that's the lawyer who
also worked with his late father Robert
Kardashian senior on the OJ Simpson case
I personally on mr. Kardashian's behalf
apologized and offered our regrets for
what has taken place
Robin China's relationship has been
volatile from the very beginning with
both sides being accused of milking the
drama for personal publicity in April of
2016
Rob popped the question to black China
with a 7 carat ring a month later
China announced she was pregnant you are
the father in November the couple
welcomed their little girl dream to the
world China says they split the
following month they also called off a
second season of their reality show and
then
Wednesday the fifth that meltdown China
told GMA she felt betrayed I was
devastated
of course I'm like how could somebody
like the host these pictures of me and
I'm like wow okay
[Music]
you